put another nickel in the alex jones was
right jar it turns out that whatever
they are putting in the water is not
only turning the frickin frogs gay but
it's posing a serious danger to our
health and now all of a sudden the epa
is admitting it
we've got
a story just came out from usa today epa
finds no safe level for two toxic
forever chemicals found in many u.s
water systems
these quote forever chemicals are linked
to different types of cancer low birth
weights and other ailments one expert
said this will set off alarm bells so
there are all sorts of contaminants in
the water
and the the epa will say okay well if
it's below this threshold then it's fine
but if it's above this threshold then
it's not fine uh what the epa has
discovered is that two of these
contaminants are not safe at any level
any level that can ever possibly be
measured they're still very dangerous to
human beings and so they've now got to
work to take all of that out of the
water for 60 years
these guys have been mocking
american people regular old americans as
rubes and kooks and idiots for asking if
maybe there's some dangerous stuff in
the water supply now they tell us there
are multiple contaminants in the water
that are not safe at any level the chief
issue here
is not that we might currently all be
poisoning ourselves
my problem is not even that our public
authorities got this and so many other
things wrong
my main issue
is the arrogance
the haughtiness
the absolute disdain with which our
genius rulers look on all those rube
idiot americans who have the temerity to
question their wisdom my issue is that
almost every single day now it seems the
supposed genius experts who run our
country are being made to look like
fools by the people that they all used
to accuse of wearing tin foil hats i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from seoul sivir
silver snorlax who says i tied a cinder
block around my ankle before going
swimming today on the advice of an
expert it was terrible and i almost
drowned but imagine how much worse it
would have been if i didn't have the
cinder block tied around my legs such a
great point we got to make sure
goodness sakes people tie those
cinderblocks around your legs the
experts say so and they can't be proven
wrong they literally cannot be proven
wrong because anything that happens they
say proves them
right
we need to talk to each other the the
mass messages that we are getting from
the institutions and the big propaganda
outlets they are not serving us very
well we need to speak to one another and
communicate when you want to communicate
i strongly recommend you check out
puretalk right now go to puretalk.com
use promo code knowles podcast later on
we're getting to my favorite time of the
week that is the mailbag now with the
voicemail bag and that voicemail bag is
brought to you by puretalk i totally
love these guys if you want to keep more
of your money if you want to save money
from woke sell companies that are just
spending it on all sorts of nonsense if
you want to keep the voicemail back on
this show go switch to puretalk now you
are getting the exact same quality
service as all those other companies
that you're saving a ton of money you
can get the unlimited talks the
unlimited text six gigs of data
beautiful 5g network
puretalk.com what's the catch there
isn't one there's no catch go to
puretalk.com
a plan enter the promo code knowles
podcast save 50 off your first month you
can be switched over to puretalk in less
than 10 minutes that is promo code
knowles podcast
p o kowles
c a s t all one word at puretalk.com
pure talk is simply smarter
wireless
i'm not sure i want to be citing usa
today on this water story it's been
reported elsewhere so i suppose we can
assume that it's real i saw the press
release from the epa but i don't know
that i would trust usa today because usa
today just found itself in a huge
journalistic scandal yesterday
usa today announced that it would be
deleting 23 articles
almost two dozen articles why is that
they're all by the same writer gabriella
miranda and they had to delete them
because it turns out that those articles
were fake news
they weren't just fake news in the sense
that
they got some facts wrong
they
even that they slightly misquoted
something they were fake news in that
they were just completely made up
this reporter this breaking news
reporter for usa today
was just making up quotes people out of
whole cloth and then writing works of
fiction and then publishing those works
on usa today why is this a big deal well
one because usa today used to have some
kind of reputation and now that
reputation has taken a big big hit
but there's a political problem too
which is that usa today is a trusted
source on social media
when something appears in usa today that
helps to push social media algorithms in
a certain direction
but it can't be a trusted source they
just deleted almost two dozen articles
because they were totally fake
daily wire has never had to delete two
dozen articles for fake news have we
gotten everything 100 right all the time
no there's occasionally a problem here
an error here you go in and you correct
it
we've never had anything
anywhere close to this
and yet daily wire is not considered a
trusted super-duper special non-partisan
unbiased news source for the social
media algorithm
on the contrary we rely on those
algorithms we rely on the all of these
supposedly trusted sources to back up
what we're saying and if they contradict
us then very often social media will
suppress what we have to say
my problem here
is is not even that there is such a
thing as trusted sources i know some
people are so skeptical of the power in
big tech
are so skeptical of the power in in our
corporate press that they don't think we
should have any trusted sources it's
that social media and the public square
should just be a total wild west where
no no one organization carries any more
weight than any other i'm not even
saying that no there look there are
total rags out there that i don't think
should carry a lot of weight in the
public square my problem isn't that
there are trusted sources quote unquote
my problem is that the trusted sources
that that our public square relies on
are not trustworthy
i don't even mean to beat up usa today
usa today is far from the worst offender
of this
the fact that the new york times counts
as a trusted source is preposterous the
new york times is not fit to line a
person's bird cage you think of the fake
news that the new york times has spread
just on the russia hoax alone in the
last five years it's a joke and there
have been so many other do you think
about the fake news that that the new
york times has spread about january sex
there are really anything having any to
do with donald trump and the the
effective parts of the republican party
why is that a trusted source i i'm not
saying this
in in a self-serving manner or at least
not exclusively in a self-serving manner
the daily wire is a much more reliable
trustworthy source than the new york
times
the daily wire the michael knowles show
in particular you know you hear things
here first i take out my crystal ball as
nostradamus i tell you what's going to
happen in the future
this show this news outlet
is a much more trustworthy source we
have a much better record of accuracy
than the washington post than cnn
obviously than abc cbs nbc than any of
the supposedly trusted news sources
we've got experts you know we've got
experts out there beyond just the news
organizations and we are supposed to
trust the experts who's who is the
number one expert quote unquote in the
country
you know
you know who i'm talking about out there
of course it's dr fauci he's the number
one
expert whatever he says is the law he
has got more power
than the ancient pharaohs than any
dictator has presumed to have this
whatever he says it not only is
policy whatever he says
is the science he says he's a
representative of the science and yet
fauci consistently
gets things wrong now you have our
public health establishment just use one
example
encouraging
the fouchy ouchie the boosters the jabs
all that stuff in very very little kids
so during a coveted hearing yesterday
senator rand paul
asked for any scientific evidence at all
to back up that policy fauci comes up
empty
what is the possibility if your kid has
had coveted which is 75 of the country's
head covered what is the chance that my
child's going to the hospital or dying
if you look at the number of deaths in
pediatrics senator
you can see that there are more deaths
of people who have had it
but people have had the disease
senator we also know from other studies
that the optimal degree of protection
when you get infection is to get
vaccinated after infection and in fact
showing re-infection in the era of
omicron and the sub-lineages that
vaccinations you can't answer the
question i ask the question i ask is how
many kids are dying and how many kids
are going to the hospital who have
already had covid the answer may be zero
but you're not even giving us the data
because you have so much wanted to
protect everybody from all the data
because we're not smart enough to look
at the data when you release data
earlier when the cdc released the data
they left out the category of 18 to 49
on whether or not there was a health
benefit for for adults 18 to 49 why was
it left out
when critics finally complained it was
finally included because there was no
health benefit from taking a booster
between the 18 to 49 and the cdc study
there it is there is the expert
the expert is asked a very simple
question by rand paul
dr fauci how many children are dying of
re-infection from covid it's a very
simple question
and fauci starts to answer a different
question he starts to say well among
children generally with or without a
prior infection and and rand paul says
no that's not the question my question
is how many people are dying from
reinfection
and fact she says well senator uh you
know we know that the optimal degree and
he's then he's answering a completely
unrelated question he's just he's just
spouting his talking points
and rand paul says
you just won't answer you want it why
won't he answer is it because fauci
doesn't have the data he just doesn't
know is he just an idiot maybe i could
see why you might be inclined to think
that because he doesn't come off as the
brightest bulb in the pack but then rand
paul makes a great point he says how
come
the federal government collects all of
these data about covid my goodness they
collect every little jot and title they
possibly can about covid and then when
they release the data
they leave some parts out
they only release the data that are
convenient for their narrative they'll
leave out whole age groups when it comes
to risk from covid why they just
conveniently they happen to leave out
all of the age groups that show that
covet is not as dangerous as the ruling
class led us to believe that is not just
a matter of idiocy that is not even just
a matter of ignorance
that is a matter
of corruption
now when you want to protect yourself
from all sorts of bad people and from
freeze and from fire and from flooding
you got to check out ring right now go
to ring.com
knowles
summer is here people are traveling
you're gonna be away from your home
quite a bit if you're anything like me
you can also rest easy if you're
anything like me because of ring alarm
ring alarm is the award-winning home
security system with available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe best of all you can easily
install it yourself friend of mine just
got married here do you know what i did
do you know what i gave this person for
her wedding i gave her ring alarm pro i
love it it makes a great gift it's
really really great for your home and
you can go pro you can be a pro just
like me ring alarm protects your home
your your windows your doors from freeze
fire flood
ring alarm pro protects your physical
home and your digital home to protect
your data we live so much of our lives
online
make sure you're protecting your data
they've got an incredible deal to
subscribe for professional monitoring
right now to learn more go to ring.com
knowles that's ring.com
knowles
our genius experts are not only stupid
and incompetent very often but they're
also
frequently corrupt in part of rand
paul's beautiful grilling of dr fauci
the high pontiff of public health
rand paul asks him a question not so
much about the data and the infections
and the deaths and the hospitalizations
he asks him about the money he says do
you think dr fatchi there might be any
kind of conflict of interest here there
might be any kind of big money moving
around when you guys are all making your
recommendations
can you tell me that you have not
received a royalty from any entity that
you ever oversaw the distribution of
money in research grants
um well first of all let's talk about
what's the question no that's the
question have you ever overseen it have
you ever received a royal payment from a
company that you later oversaw money
going to that company
you know i don't know as a fact but i
doubt it
well here's the thing is why don't you
let us know why don't you reveal how
much you've gotten and from what
entities the nih refuses we ask them we
ask them the nih we ask them whether or
not who got it and how much they refused
to tell us they sent it redacted
not only do they refuse to tell they'll
actually redact the specific pieces of
information that the senate is
requesting that rand paul is requesting
why
later on in that exchange fouchy
is able to turn it a little bit and he
says well listen for this specific
series of years i didn't make a lot of
money and he thinks that that is going
to put the question away but it's not
you see it from the early evasion
rand paul asks a direct question
he says hey did you guys get money
what do you do you guys get money from
these things and what does dr fashion do
listen let's talk about no let's not
talk about any nonsense that you want to
talk about faji how about you just
answer a simple question you don't want
to you don't want to and by the way even
if fouchy's not making it let's say the
fact is not making a lot of money then
why won't the nih provide this
information of the royalties that
members of these committees members of
the public health establishment are
getting
specifically with regard to companies
that they are that they are making
passing judgments on
why can't why won't the government give
you that information the very fact that
they won't provide that kind of
transparency
is is proof positive as far as i'm
concerned that there is clearly the
possibility the the open door to
corruption
the issue is not any conspiracy theory
there's nothing conspiracy theoretical
about suggesting that there can be
conflicts of interest in big politics
and we should protect against them
it's not even a question of getting rid
of the experts i have no problem with
listening to expertise and putting
expertise in its proper place
i i
don't believe that the only thing that
we can do is just destroy all of the
american scientific institutions and all
become yeoman farmers or something i'm
not saying that that's what's going to
happen
but surely the experts that we have
are no good
they're now good their predictions are
wrong they lie to us not not only get
things wrong they they will actively lie
like fauci did during during kovid
and there is a huge possibility for
corruption which is now not being dealt
with now we're just getting stonewalled
by the nih so what's the solution to
that
the solution to that is to go in and
wield political power to make it better
there are two reactions from the right
two completely different strategies for
how to deal with this kind of thing
there's one
which is the kind of
the libertarians tend to favor this
strategy more which is just get rid of
the experts
forget about the you know ignore the
experts entirely and and
take the all of the money and the power
away and then nobody gets power and we
just reduce the amount of power in the
government and reduce the amount of
power specifically in the in the
scientific bureaucracy and then
everything will be better i get why that
suggestion is tempting i get why that
sounds it does sound good
if we could just take that power out of
washington dc take that power out of the
nih or any other aspect of the deep
state i would i would love that wouldn't
that be so wonderful would that it were
so simple
the conservative solution the solution
that the conservatives generally tend to
favor more though
says
you're not you're never going to get rid
of experts
every state
every government in the history of the
entire world has had experts and has had
bureaucracies
and has had specialization and it's a
complete pipe dream to say that you're
going to get rid of that furthermore
every state every society in the history
of the world
has
political power that is conserved
political power is not just going to
disappear it's not just going to go away
you're not going to just pop it like a
balloon
it's going to go it's going to exist
especially in a big powerful country
like ours you're not going to just make
the power go away so it's just going to
move
is the power going to be
in this part of the government is the
power going to be more with the
corporations is the power going to be
more with the universities is the power
going to be more with technology is the
power going to be more in silicon valley
is the power going to be more in
washington d.c is the power going to be
more with the republicans is the power
going to be more with the democrats
some people might not like that they
might think it's kind of icky and yucky
what do you mean we can't just make the
power magically go away by waving a
magic wand i i would that it were so
simple guys but it's not
there is going to be power
the only question is going to be who is
going to wield it
where is it going to reside
and what is it going to be wielded in
service of
i'm not giving you some kind of utopian
dream fantasy of how we're going to just
knock down all the buildings in
washington dc and send all of those deep
state bureaucrats to saint helena and
then we're going to return to the
republic of the 1790s and all will be
well again no that's not going to happen
i i don't think it's going to happen i
don't even really
i don't even really want it to happen
it's just so fantastical to suggest
anything like that
the question right now is what do we do
i think very very easily you could
well one just to rand paul's point you
could
demand a little bit more transparency on
the conflicts of interests that these
guys have you could
take some of the power away from the
fouchies of the world and give it back
to the rand pauls of the world that
would be that would be an improvement
take some power away from the scientific
bureaucracy give it back to the senate
maybe take some power away from the
federal government give it back to the
states you're not saying we're going to
magically get rid of power here but you
you can move it around in such a way
that's more conducive to flourishing to
a traditional american government
and you can move some power away from
these idiot experts these jerks these
corrupt people these deceivers these
these ah they're just so awful you could
take some power away from those experts
and give it to our experts
you could take some power away from the
democrats and give it to the republicans
is that a perfect solution for all time
no but it would it would
do quite a lot to improve the state of
our country in the state of corruption
and then if the republicans screw it up
then we'll go to somebody else
if the new experts screw up we'll go to
somebody else and we will keep this
thing moving so that power doesn't
become so concentrated and in this
horrible elite that becomes so corrosive
to to the american form of government
we're getting all sorts of bad answers
from the biden administration right now
uh ducey peter ducey at fox news just
grilled the new press secretary
karine jean-pierre
he asked her
why is inflation so bad and the press
secretary gave this answer that the
white house has been pushing
on television in the press
which is look inflation is no worse here
than it is anywhere in the world it's
actually much much worse it's better
here
than anywhere else and it's much worse
overseas and so stop complaining about
inflation and peter ducey
looks down at some of those numbers he
says wait a second that's just not true
i did it globally though he says that
inflation is worse everywhere but here
that's not true the u.s has worse
inflation than germany france japan
canada india italy saudi arabia so why
is he saying i think what we are saying
is that uh
when you talk about inflation it is a
global thing and it is not just about
the united states this is something that
everyone is feeling because of coming
out of once once in a lifetime pandemic
because of the war that russia has
started in ukraine no that's not what
you said
you're changing your answer now
previously you said inflation is worse
everywhere else
come on it's relatively not that bad
here and then peter ducey says no it's
actually
relatively really bad here even relative
to other places in the world and then
karine jambir says no look we're just
pointing out it's like a global thing
know that that is not what you pointed
out that is not what you said
either you guys just got the numbers
completely wrong and you're incompetent
or you knew what the real numbers were
and you lied
either way not good either way does not
speak very highly of our current
ruling elite
it's a very it's a very different
country that we are living in right now
compared to
well
certainly compared to the country that
we had at the at the start of the united
states it's a very different country
that we're living in right now compared
to the country we had three years ago i
had this thought the other day i said do
you remember
when trump was president and pretty much
everything was better do you remember
that seems so long ago
what about what about other historical
what kind of country
are we living in now and going to be
living in in the future
the country that the libs want to give
us
is not the historical american nation
george washington university
is named after george washington
it it
resides in washington d.c it's also
named after george washington
george washington is the father of the
country their mascot is a colonial who
looks like george washington
they're called the colonials
well the school just voted to get rid of
it in the name of inclusivity
here is what the school said
a moniker must unify our community draw
people together and serve as a source of
pride
this is the chairman of the school's
board of trustees we look forward to the
next steps in an inclusive process to
identify a moniker that fulfills this
aspiration
it's got to be
really inclusive
i suspect
that
if you took a poll of americans
most americans still like george
washington
i think george washington is pretty
inclusive
gw pushes policies
that are not so inclusive of everyone's
views
gw pushes transgenderism
right i don't if a if a boy wants to go
into the girl dress up like a girl going
to the girls bathroom at gw i strongly
suspect
that he would be allowed to do that
that's not inclusive
it's inclusive of
that deluded man and
his
small band of other deluded people but
it's not inclusive of the views of the
majority of americans far from it
so when they say inclusivity
they're describing inclusivity for their
group
they're they're describing
inclusivity for an extremely exclusive
group that doesn't include you
that you used to hear this line about
about the senate about about the
political elite broadly they say it's a
big club and you ain't in it
when we hear the word inclusion
some people are deceived to believing
that means we just include everybody no
it doesn't it means we include everyone
in this extremely corrupt
stupid elite and we exclude
everybody else that's what it really
means
even now to the point where you've got
these radicals at the university saying
we're gonna we're gonna cancel george
washington
at george washington university
in washington dc
who are you gonna replace him with
either
you're going to just become completely
nothing completely generic remember they
got rid of the redskins and they called
it the washington football team for a
while now now they call it the
commanders which is still pretty bland
not quite as bland as the washington
football team
so either you're gonna do that
or you're going to
pick some radical who i promise you is
less
popular
and almost certainly less virtuous than
george washington what's it going to be
the new mascot is ibrahim x kendy
of gw university here is our new mascot
a drag queen
happy pride month everybody drag queens
are everywhere now that's going to be
our new inclusive mascot isn't that
don't you feel like that's very
inclusive
when i was an undergraduate there was
going to be a
class-wide dance and i think it was
themed after gone with the wind or the
south or something like that and i think
it was gone with the wind though
and then some
liberal northerner took issue with this
some white liberal northerner took issue
with this and said that's racist it's
terrible it's not inclusive
mind you this was
13 14 years ago things hadn't gotten
nearly as crazy as they are now but you
saw the seeds of it already
this is not this is not inclusive at all
this is terrible and so what what did
the theme become any theme that we tried
to pick
someone could contrive a problem with
oh no well this theme is offensive to
this group this theme could be
misconstrued to be offensive to this
group this theme upholds a norm and a
standard that now is considered
unfashionable and politically incorrect
and so there's no
we do you know what theme we ended up
going with
blue
blue was the theme
because no one yet was able to come up
with a with a an issue to have with blue
though probably they would now is this
the country we want to live in
it seems like either way this this i've
been radicalized by this gw mascot issue
because
it can only take our country in one of
two ways both of which are worse than
the current way the one way that it
could take us is to get rid of all
particular things anything that is
particular
nice beautiful you can have an
attachment to goes away and now
everything's just bland and generic
and and and totally
plain without anything that would draw
you to it or it goes in the direction of
particular radicals
so we get we we cancel thomas jefferson
and we exalt
ibram x candy
or malcolm x or somebody like that
or angela angela davis is a good example
of this angela davis is an actual
communist who was incredibly accused i
think of of terrorism and now she is
considered this great luminary bill
ayers of the weather underground bill
ayers was considered a mentor to barack
obama
radical leftist terrorist bill ayers
though he gets he's he's exalted he's
fetid
but
john adams george washington those guys
were terrible got to cancel them got to
tear down their statues speaking of that
washington football team
jack del rio coach over there
with the commanders he just got in a
whole lot of trouble because he had the
audacity to contradict the official
regime genius expert narrative on
january 6th
i see the images on tv
people's livelihoods are being destroyed
businesses are being burned down
no problem
and then we have a dust up at the
capitol
well there's nothing burned down
and we're not going to talk about we're
going to make that a major deal i just
think
it's kind of two standards
and if we apply the same standard
and we're going to be reasonable with
each other let's have a discussion
let's be reasonable let's have a
discussion
let's compare similar events
that guy
nearly got cancelled for those comments
he got a massive fine i think it was
about a hundred thousand dollars he's
now at the the target of a ton of attack
pieces why because what did he say
he said you know that dust up at the
capitol not saying it was good
but i'm saying relative to other
insurrections violent uprisings what
it's it wasn't a big deal that's just
true that's just a fact we know that
january 6th was not the worst
insurrection in history we know it
wasn't the worst insurrection of the
year that would have been blm but even
look at a tax on the capital
1915 a harvard professor blows up the
senate reception room sets off
explosives in the senate reception room
19
when was it
1943 or
53 i think it was 1953 you had a group
of puerto rican
activists who shot up the house of
representatives injured five members of
congress 1971 the weather underground
you know bill ayers organization the
weather underground radical leftist
group blew up part of the senate
a little over 10 years later another
radical group another radical leftist
group
blew up another part of the senate
did did the gen generator or six people
blow up the senate did they shoot up the
house of representatives did they do
really anything other than dance around
in a horn hat crack a coors light in the
rotunda and make a mess of nancy
pelosi's desk i'm not even excusing that
but the language that jack rio is using
here is absolutely precise and he's not
allowed to say it he's not a so which
which narrative or do you think is more
accurate
the narrative that you're getting from
cnn washington post abc nbc new york
times liz cheney nancy pelosi everything
big tech everything that january 6 was
the worst event ever in the whole
history our democracy was on the brink
of collapse or
this guy this football coach
who says yeah you know let's have a
conversation about that little dust up
back there let's just be reasonable and
have cooler heads which one which one do
you think is more accurate which do you
think is more precise
my problem is not
with experts my problem is not with
talking about political events my
problem is
my problem is with
this current crop
and the answer to this current crop of
experts
hollowed out institutions
political rulers
the answer is not to bury our heads in
the sand and hope that the power goes
away
the answer is not to pretend that
there's some kind of neutrality here and
we can find some neutral i don't see any
neutral ground the answer is to take
political power away from them
and redistribute that they love
redistributing things redistribute that
political power it to experts who are
who have greater expertise
to public servants who are more
interested in serving the public
to
institutions that are more conducive to
human flourishing the answer is to
engage in that political process and to
wield the power that we get
you know
right now one
there's political power all throughout
our country obviously in the senate
obviously in the courts obviously in big
tech entertainment is one that
conservatives often neglect well we at
the daily wire are not neglecting it
we've got a big movie we uncanceled gina
carano that movie is available right now
that's over at the daily wire
dailywire.com subscribe
you can watch terror on the prairie with
gina carano we'll be right back with the
voicemail bag
i love the voicemail bag this is my
favorite thing that we've done on the
show in years if you want to keep the
voicemail back
voicemail bag continuing you need to
switch your cell phone service to pure
talk
i love pure talk they are sponsoring the
voicemail bag they're making it possible
go to puretalk.com select a plan enter
promo code knowles podcast save 50 off
your first month you will save a ton of
money you will get exactly the same high
quality service that you've got now
maybe you'll end up getting better
service but most importantly you will
keep the voice mail bag coming so i can
hear your dulcet tones all right let's
take it away with the first question
hey there mr michael my name is stanley
i just want to say first off i'm a big
fan i'm one of those came for ben state
for michael kind of guys and of all the
questions i might ask you about your
thoughts on politics religion
you know relationships etc really the
one question i would love for you to
answer and i'm so glad the voicemail is
here because i didn't know how to ask
you this in a written email why do you
pronounce certain words with a short i
sound rather than a long i sound words
like divisive rather than divisive or
words like
ideology rather than ideology to me i
would take the root word idea or divide
and make it ideology or divisive so i
want to know why you do the ideology or
divisive kind of pronunciation otherwise
i'd love to hear what you have to say
have a great one
the answer this is a very very good
question the answer to this question is
extremely complicated but the short
version is
because it's a fallen world my friend
that's why that's why i pronounce
certain so for ideology
i believe that ideology or ideology are
both considered somewhat common and
acceptable pronunciations
but you've hit on the word that is very
divisive and that would be the word
divisive and i think in the case of
divisive i think my pronunciation is
technically incorrect
it's it's become popular especially in
politics but it is i believe incorrect
i googled this some time ago because i
was having a debate with a friend over
divisive or divisive and apparently it
is a mispronunciation first popularized
by george h.w bush
then popularized again by barack obama
i i believe it is the common
pronunciation in canada america's hat
but in america and in the united kingdom
in england
the
preferred pronunciation is divisive
and i just i just say it wrong i find it
easier to say divisive that's a tough
one the word there's another word one
this one i definitely get correct but it
bothers people
schism versus schism people want to say
schism it's not it's cism that's one
that drives people absolutely up there's
so many i say coffee because i'm from
new york some people say
coffee i don't know i actually don't
know how people say it you know i don't
there there is some variation here but i
i
as prescriptivist as i am when it comes
to language
i will have the humility to admit
sometimes i get it wrong and i'm so damn
stubborn i won't change next question
hello nostradamus my best friend who
lives in another country recently told
me that by december of next year she
will either conceive a child with a
partner or will be artificially
inseminated i asked her why she wouldn't
want to find a man who would stick
around for her and commit to her in a
child and she told me that she would
prefer that but her end goal is to have
a baby and she's perfectly fine with
being a single mother if her timeline
runs out
and she's left with artificial
insemination she told me that she wants
a baby more than anything which is
understandable because
we're both 19 we talked about marriage
and children since we met
five years ago and we even talked about
wedding dresses and everything that
girls talk about about marriage in the
future um but my question is how can i
help my best friend find a guy who will
commit to her and a child and if she
goes the other route how can i be a
supportive friend for her and this baby
regardless of the circumstances of their
conception thank you for advice and love
the show
wow
that was a real shock right there in the
middle of that question i was kind of
going along with the question i
understand it i think a lot of people
are dealing with some of these issues
then you said the girl's 19 if i'm not
pregnant by next summer i'm gonna i'm
gonna artificially inseminate myself and
intentionally deprive my child of his or
her father
at
19
it's not like your biological clock is
running out at that point okay that well
that makes it an extremely clear-cut
case tell your friend to stop being so
damn selfish and recognize that a baby
is not all about her
she's obviously not ready to be a mother
because she still is only viewing the
world entirely through her own desires
and the the satisfaction of her own
caprices and appetites the bait what is
good for the baby is the question
there's no question it is much better
for a baby to be raised in a stable home
with a mother and a father who are
married to each other there's no
question about that it's not that you
can't have a good life being raised by a
single mother or being raised in some
kind of difficult circumstance or
anything of course you can
and people can do that wonderfully it's
a that's a
but it's not ideal
if you if you had your choice
it's not that you know the husband
leaves it's not that a spouse dies it's
not that there's there's some difficult
circumstances if it just you're you're
planning it out
no it's extremely selfish to choose to
bring a baby into the world
intentionally to deprive that baby of
his natural father and his natural
mother joined together in matrimony to
to intentionally deprive that that child
of any kind of fatherly influence in his
life it's just that's just a terrible
thing to do so tell your friend to stop
being so damned selfish
right now she's thinking of it as
a wonderful gift that she can give the
gift of life and then she she's she's
trying to position herself in her own
mind as the the sort of hero this
wonderful giving person i think you need
to make it clear to your friend
she is being extremely
selfish as is often the case is often
the case you know it's it's not that
it's not that your friend has a tiny
heart
it's that her heart is not in the right
place this is a line that chesterton
used about his friend george bernard
shaw he said bernard shaw has a great
great heart
this socialist playwright bernard shaw
but the conservative christian
chesterton said the problem is his
heart's not in the right place tell your
friend to get her heart in the right
place
meet a man the normal way get married
get settled
have children the right way next
question
hi michael love your show
um this week my company came out with a
company diversity equity and inclusion
style guide just so we don't make any
missteps
and i notice while going through it that
we're instructed not to capitalize white
um because that refers to that goes back
to white supremacy
and but we are supposed to capitalize
black in all instances
so i'm wondering how that's not racist
and what your thoughts are on that
thanks
well it obviously is racist i don't know
that the word racist means anything
anymore i try to use even more specific
language
the
the policy is designed to punish white
people and to give an advantage to black
people to say that white people are
worse than black
let you know peop that that's just what
the symbolism suggests you're
lowercasing the word white because white
people are lesser than black people who
deserve more and and that is represented
in the capital letter b so i would not
do that i would not follow that policy
i'm not saying you have to quit your job
i'm not saying you even need to make a
big hullabaloo at the diversity
equity training or anything but i would
not go along with that policy and if if
one of your superiors has a problem with
that i think you can very calmly explain
and say you know i just find this very
racist and so i'm i'm not going to go
along with that and if they insist upon
it then you you might you might want to
consider other employment
because
especially when we're talking about
language this is not just uh your your
manager telling you hey hey go over
there and do that grunt work that you
don't want to do and maybe maybe you you
don't really want to go do it but hey
that's your job you're getting a
paycheck and you're gonna go when we're
talking about language
this is your manager saying hey
discard your beliefs
hey
say something that you know isn't true
or that say something that you think is
evil or say something that you think is
not conducive to human flourishing that
that's a that's far more insidious i
would i would
i would not be able to do that next
question
all right michael i've got one for you
i'm an anesthesia provider in a blue
state that does gender affirmation
surgeries yes my institution cuts
perfectly functioning body parts off
people
with underdeveloped prefrontal cortexes
and
mental illnesses my question is is how
do i conduct myself in an atmosphere i
do not want to be in
i love what i do
this is only a sliver
of
what i do as an anesthesia provider but
i have a very difficult time in the
operating room surrounded by people who
were given the title of doctor although
they
fail on
maintaining objective reality and truth
and doing this and they consistently
call girls boys and boys girls give me
some advice uh
anything will help thanks
really tough problem i don't think you
necessarily need to quit your job
but i
i would not be able to participate in
those kinds of surgeries so you say it
doesn't happen frequently maybe but
when when little kids come in and their
psycho parents and these sick doctors
decide to put them under and then chop
off their body parts
you might be called in to provide the
anesthesia
if i were you i would not be able to do
that i i don't i
i think it would probably disturb your
sleep at night i think your conscience
will probably bother you because of that
i would i would not participate there
are different different degrees to which
people participate in evil there are
really indirect ways
a really indirect way that one could
participate in evil is by going over and
eating a girl scout cookie at a friend's
house and the girl scout cookie funds
the girl scouts organization of america
and some chapters of a girl scouts
organization used to partner with
planned parenthood and so
as a result you're basically performing
an abortion when you eat your friend's
cookie right well there is a there is a
remote participation with evil there
perhaps but it's not it's not a very
direct one at a certain point you can't
really operate in the world if depending
on how removed you become from this the
very fact that you and i pay taxes means
that we are
funding planned parenthood
just to stick on that same example so
there are
there are
there is nuance when we're talking about
a very very remote participation with
evil you're not you're not morally
required to participate with evil in in
any way certainly not but it's it's a
different situation than when we're
talking about a direct participation
with an evil act so i would i would i
would say no to that
and i i like to think that your
your superiors would accommodate that i
i know some people who work in the
medical field who say they they're not
going to do that kind of thing
specifically on transgender surgeries
and
the people that i know have who have who
have voiced those concerns have been
accommodated your mileage may vary and
you might need to go to a different
health care center but that's that's the
way i would parse the issue all right
one more question from rosalie michael i
need your advice i've always had the
problem of wanting everyone to like me
which i know is impossible especially as
a right-wing conservative i've heard
people say just get over it but i need
more advice than that how do you handle
the liberal attacks and do you have any
suggestions on how i can speak up for
what i believe is right without getting
emotional and letting the libs get under
my skin yes
i like it when people like me i don't
need people to like me obviously i would
have chosen a different profession had i
and i really needed people to like me
but i like it i i don't i don't get a
thrill when everybody hates me i know
that some people feel that way and they
they want to always be the object of
scorn in any room and but i i don't i i
like it when everybody can get along
okay
so then if you're inclined that way as
it seems that you are how do you
deal with it when
you are maybe an otherwise perfectly
lovely
charitable nice kind person whom
everyone should love but because of your
politics at least half the country hates
you and because of the liberal skew of
the culture
the number is probably even higher
this is where christianity is very
helpful for two reasons one look at what
they did to jesus okay they when you say
things that are true
well in the case of jesus when you are
the truth then they really come at you
and even when you say things that are
true when you when you take the side of
truth
that's generally unpopular that's been
true since the very beginning of the
world almost the very very beginning of
the world certainly since sin and death
pervades the world so uh you can take
some solace and comfort in that and then
there is the traditional christian and
certainly now this would be considered a
catholic point of view that suffering is
sanctifying that suffering is not just a
bad thing that people endure and it's
really annoying and it's sad and it's
just just generally depressing no
suffering can be a good thing when we
suffer we can kiss it up to god that's
that's another old way of talking about
it that actually the greatest saints in
history have suffered a great deal our
lord suffered as much as could be
suffered on the cross and so
when when that happens we are we are
in a way connecting ourselves to christ
this is what saint paul writes about
this he says
i rejoice in my sufferings i am making
up in my flesh uh that is that which is
lacking in the cross of christ which is
a
really
pregnant uh line of the scriptures
but this is this is that connection
there that we are we are we are doing in
some way
doing some good when we endure suffering
with patience and with grace suffering
is not uh it's a moral category it's not
that it's just really really bad it's
not even that it's just really really
good suffering is just a fact of the
world the the only question that you
have is how will you react to suffering
will you react to suffering in a whiny
petulant uh self-absorbed
uh destructive way or will you react to
suffering in a way that is sanctifying
and edifying and lifts your eyes up to
heaven hopefully the latter my friend
i'm michael nola's the michael knowles
show see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin